donc les chroniqueurs sont derrière
cette porte est bon en créant babolat
faut chauffer c'est bien c'est mélangé à
fond alors on y va attention non
toc toc toc toc toc toc foot comme en
foot et c'est le foot
ouais c'est qui footfoot qui fout ta
cagoule
oui
[Applaudissements]
bien
ça va et pas mal marseillais ramazzotti
d'offres pas mal pas mal mort cellulaire
au pinceau un pick up beat of great
confiant pour eux marseille franchement
on est confiant on est toujours un
challenge à huy bien des photos de vous
retrouver moyens beau maillot de l'om je
suis ravi donc il va tout va bien donc
et a vu un
ah ouais je ne vous est pas inconnu sur
le coup cherabi sur a quand même oui on
dirait toit en gène quoi
merci beaucoup d'offres pour cette mise
en valeur allègre toc toc toc
s'il est ok loki qui le hockey et bat
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal enlever le casque pour
voir ce que confirme à craon le casque
non métisse etc et je vous plais alors
enlevé mon club sur le truc c'est le
bureau si on perd on n'est pas non plus
ma mère mais enlever le casque vous
savez que le casque l'enlèvement n'est
pas compatible avec les pires
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le mobile est ce que vous allez me
depuis hier écoutez vous étiez à côté de
la plaque au témoin bien c'était ce fut
véritablement et j'embrasse toutes les
personnes qui m'ont envoyé plein de
messages sur les réseaux d'ailleurs
c'était l'expérience la plus bouleversé
pour rappeler que ludivine c'est fait
hypnotisé mais à quand on va taper sur
la gauche on peut des napperons et quand
on perd mais sans la payer aux éclats
mais un truc de dingue
on est conscient en étant un puissant
service est très très élevé sur les
qu'on sent qu'on est ridicule ou pas
allons-y comme toc toc
et là c'est le tir bas le dire qu'ils
tirent brûlés au vent bellande de pierre
bah
c'est le connemara c'est un peu un tube
oui c'est le seul mec depuis 35 ans
connaît pas les paroles quoi est ce que
j'annonce et des sportifs oui en quoi là
je suis en tireur de ball-trap avec
bruno boudé dans baltringue la vie
résumé chanson nina connemara ils seront
soit il s'embête pas et ben bravo pour
ce qu'on a mis un budget sur les
déguisements ce vendredi là avait elle
alors les visites aller là alors je vous
mets au défi de reconnaître le sport en
question a épicé un sport ça se pratique
pas dans un stade
croyez moi toc toc toc ses limites
pardon la quitte la lutte la multi lit
très bien value
[Applaudissements]
ouais
alors elle est mignonne nom alors je
n'ai pas dit qu'elle n'était pas
mignonne gla manon c'est donc la lutte
c'est un casque de ghada de hockey ça
non il manque surtout c'est un canon
benjamin surtout tinky winky alors c'est
réglementaire le collier la trouvais ça
je dis à tous mes petits points de
féminité alors je pense qu'on vous a
menti c'est très sympa mais en même
temps nous rester comme ça c'est en même
temps il faut le porter plus porter très
bien c'est parce que c'est quand même
près du corps à ses très moulant ah bah
oui comment s'appelle comment sa valeur
à faycelles eu un flash
aller à l'école pop suivant on a reconnu
bois pareil le lancer de marteau a
troqué le lancer de marteau
je donnerai le jour vieux
[Applaudissements]
après la lutte
certains de ces bâtiments abritant
lanceur de marteau est aussi un
basketteur je fais double casquette ça
et en rien en rien de son nez vendredi
ont préféré donc c'est tellement zen
martos à lancer de marteau absolument
mais est aussi une autre chanson
savez-vous planter les choux à la mode
c'est non merci je pense que vous a
préparé une grande et belle émission way
est une imitation dans un instant ou
parfaire votre et qu'elle tease notation
une irritation je suis comme ça tout lui
à l'époque lui manche qu'elle a acquis y
celle là qui qui qui saura qui sait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre adoumim puisque vous avez vendredi
des pmp ouvert à tous c'est donc quelle
bête
abbas et pour ça il n'y a pas de
déguisement à ma taille en fait un vrai
problème
annoncée elle c'est impressionnant alors
oui si c'est un grand grand grand grand
sportif
le jour où je démissionne homme est un
mec il est comme ça et comme ça amène
enfin on aviva de vente comme ça
pourquoi on n'irait pas franchement je
passerai la montée très bien aller toc
toc toc suivant c'est le ski le ski ski
[Rires]
il n'ya pas cyril c'est un bordel
l'émission ça serait jamais avec ce
n'est jamais jamais ça et je sais sa
hotte de secondes laissez-moi
recommencer et mashima séquence henry va
alors c'est qui celle à skis et ski qui
ce qui a le droit ce qui est a le droit
[Musique]
via
[Applaudissements]
brian aiello non mais attendez pas la
lentille mais qu'est-ce qui cela mais il
a bu du vin chaud vous rendez compte en
ouvrir la journée mondiale du sport qui
veut rapprocher les peuples et sportifs
mondiaux
le chemin pour rentrer à madame les
étangs skieurs des coudes ou à quelle
heure là un homme est décédé ce qui
n'est pas parfait ménages j'en ai
j'allais oublier j'en ai jamais oublier
étendue et attention pas des mois une
sociétaire parmi les sociétés les
doyennes des dons d'habits à les toc toc
toc c'est isabelle non mais cette année
vous remercie d dont la cession cette
fumée truc
[Applaudissements]
vraiment mais franchement vanille là
franchement ils ont pris déguisement qui
m'ont vraiment bien en valeur
ça fait pas un pli ça fait plusieurs
[Musique]
semaines
treize enfants restent en forte baisse
de la valorisation de la femme
[Applaudissements]